the masks also are just really dumb
okay they're dumb i'm not saying they
don't work sometimes i'm not saying
there's not a place for masks
i'm not saying that in all circumstances
you shouldn't wear masks
but the masks generally are dumb and
nobody seriously
believes that they're going to save them
least of all
the mainstream media the news media who
are telling people to wear them how do i
know this
because msnbc sent a reporter out into
the field
to shame people for not wearing masks
but the segment didn't go that well
when one of the people that the reporter
was shaming decided to point out that
the cameraman himself
was not wearing a mask are the people
there just not worried about it cal
they're not worried about their own
personal safety
i haven't met anybody who is i met some
folks actually from lake geneva who
lived in the area they were staying a
few miles outside of town where i were
and they said they're worried about it
they're worried about that second spike
they're worried about folks coming in
from chicago
but they'll quickly add at the same time
this is a place that relies
on that business i think people here
want a little bit more funding when it
comes to these programs so that they
could stay close but again
i think people felt like the supreme
court made the decision here in
wisconsin that it was time to open up
but you can see here just around
nobody's wearing them
nobody's uh cameraman there you go
including the camera yeah
striking images cal perry oh
but they just can't they don't i guess
these reporters never took an improv
class so they've got their narrative
right here's the narrative
masks are really important and helpful
and these
irresponsible people probably trump
voters if you ask me
they're not wearing masks so they're the
bad people and we need to shame them on
national television maybe they'll lose
their job maybe they'll lose their dogs
i don't know but they're really bad
people and then one of the really bad
people points out he goes hey
hey buddy if masks are so important why
is your cameraman not wearing one
and and the reporter doesn't know how to
respond to that because he's just got
his narrative he doesn't know
how to improvise when he gets thrown off
his obviously fictitious
script she goes yeah and including the
cameraman okay
yep just completely undercut my argument
yeah i have no credibility what so
whatsoever i'm a hack i'm a liar on
television back to you katie
and katie goes yep that's right pretty
crazy images out there
next time we'll have to make sure that
all those people telling the truth
are kept far from the camera
they don't neither of those journalists
react to the reality which is that even
nba msnbc doesn't think these masks
matter that much at all
it's just fake it's just it's just a
performance
it's every bit the performance that
those two people on msnbc
were putting on that's not me saying
that that's them saying that right
they're the ones not wearing the mask
all i can do is observe and what i am
observing is
the very people telling us that the
masks matter
are the people not wearing masks you saw
this in the white house briefing the
other
day oh the reporter very i think who was
it it was one of the cnn reporters
wearing a mask for all the questions on
camera the minute she thought the
cameras went off she takes the mask off
she doesn't think the mask matters it's
just a political cudgel
it's just a way to signal her virtue to
all of her followers and to make
trump look like a mean terrible bad guy
you